Let's start by defining what is the session.
Well, let's start by defining what is the session.
Well, when a user logs into a system, when they've properly identified themselves, when they've authenticated themselves,
and they've been authorized into the system, that begins what is known as a session.
And we want to manage these sessions. We want to make sure that these sessions are secure.
Because one of the major things we want to watch out for is something called session hijacking.
Session hijacking is where an attacker, a baddie, somehow takes over a user session.
And a session, of course, means that the user is authenticated. They have access to the system.
So if someone takes over hijacks your session, it means that they would have the same rights as you.
There's a bunch of different ways of conducting session hijacking.
It can be very complicated. It can also be very simple. For instance, if I were to log into my laptop and then walk away,
while my laptop is still logged in, and someone else was to come up to my laptop and start using a laptop,
what have they done with my session? They have hijacked it.
So it can be as simple as that. It can also be very complicated, hijacking, VPN sessions, all sorts of things like that.
Here's a good question. What's the very best way of preventing session hijacking?
Well, the very best way is to actually force reauthentication.
So if your screensaver comes up and requires you to log back in,
if you require someone to put in their password again,
it's going to, if you terminate the session and then require someone to reauthenticate,
anyone that had hijacked the session has now lost access.
So the perfect answer of how we prevent session hijacking is very simple.
It's actually to force reauthentication.
And if you're really concerned about high session hijacking, you might even move to almost continuous reauthentication.
For example, some VPN solutions are actually doing this behind the scenes,
without us even realizing they're constantly reauthenticating to trying to prevent something like session hijacking.
Now let's talk about some of the different methods that we use for managing sessions.
The first one, known as schedule limitations,
actually controls when you're allowed to open or create a session.
So the idea here is that if an organization's employees all work from 8 a.m. to 5 p.m. Monday through Friday,
then schedule limitations could be set up to only allow users to create a session to log in to their system
between, say, 8 a.m. and 5 p.m. Monday through Friday.
If someone tried it Saturday night at 2 a.m., they would just be blocked.
They would say, nope, session cannot be created right now.
So that's the idea of session limitations.
The next one is log in limitations.
And this goes back to this idea that we never want to have shared accounts.
We want to have one account to one user.
And that one user should only be logged in once because they have one system.
So log in limitation is about only letting a user log in with a certain set of credentials once.
And if someone else is trying to log in with the same credentials, then you know that's a problem.
Next is timeouts.
And we use timeouts all the time.
Perfect example is your screensaver.
Your screensaver is usually set for something like 5 minutes.
And at 5 minutes of inactivity, what happens?
Well, your screensaver comes up.
And when you go back to the system and you try and you jiggle the mouse,
you get the screensaver to go away.
Before you can use the system again, what do you have to do?
Log in.
So this is an example of session timeout.
And lots of different systems do this, like an online banking system, for instance.
Well, often like log you out after 5 minutes of inactivity.
Now, let's talk about registration or the idea of identity proofing.
So identity proofing is this concept that when a new employee joins the organization,
you want to make sure that they actually are who they say they are.
You've done interviews.
You've done background checks.
You've made sure that this is the perfect employee for your organization.
But you want to make sure that when they actually show up on their first day of work,
that they are who they say they are, that you're giving out the badge, the credentials,
all the keys to the kingdom to the right person.
So how can we identity proof someone?
If they first show up for work, how can we confirm that they are who they say they are?
Well, one of the easiest ways of identity proofing someone is to ask for their government ID,
something like a driver's license or a passport.
So that's simply the concept of identity proofing.
We use it all sorts of places when someone first joins the organization.
We talked about it, we'll talk about it in relation to certificate authorities
and how a registration authority in RA will identity proof someone before they give them
a digital certificate.
So that's registration and identity proofing.